hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna make
a video about Judy and Twin Peaks real
quick though I wanted to let you know
that I'm so excited about the upcoming
Twin Peaks the final dossier book by
Mark Frost
that I've decided to do a giveaway
through my patreon account so stick
around to the end of the video to learn
more about that also I have to give a
spoiler warning here because this is
going to be from the perspective of what
we learned about Judy in the season
finale of the return aka season 3 so if
you haven't caught up with everything
then you're not gonna want to watch this
video if you heard about Judy and fire
walk with me and you haven't watched
season 3 yet just wait until afterwards
to watch this video
so judy is a name we first heard from
Phillip Jeffries when we first met him
in fire walk with me it was a really
mysterious scene so fans have been
wondering exactly what David Bowie was
talking about ever since it's been the
subject of many interesting theories and
there was even what seemed like some
crucial details that surfaced from the
fire walk with me revised scripts a few
years ago I write about this on the
internet but it originally came from the
Twin Peaks fan magazine named wrapped in
plastic
basically what they learned was that
there were earlier versions of the
script when Jeffries mentioned Judy but
he also mentioned that she had a sister
and remember there was no missing pieces
until much later so a lot of this stuff
was big news because the cut parts that
we eventually see in the missing pieces
were in the script as well so it was a
lot of stuff that came out anyway is
wrapped in plastic interviewed Robert
angles who was the co-writer of fire
walk with me and they asked him about
Judy and about some of the stuff that
was in the script that nobody saw
on-screen so he said the thing behind
judy has to do with where David Bowie
came from he was down there which he's
talking about Buenos Aires and that's
where Judy is I think Joan Chen is there
who played Josie and I think when the
Earl is there it's this idea
that there are these portals around the
world in Phillip Jeffries had one hell
of a trip to Buenos Aires and back he
really doesn't want to talk about Judy
because that reminds him of whatever
happened to him and you know there he's
referring to the actual teleportation or
whatever you want to call it I mean when
we see when he goes back to Buenos Aires
that he looks like he's in a lot of pain
from the journey anyways when asked
about Josie and if she could be the
sister of Judy Angles replied yes yes I
think that's true this idea popped up
again a couple of years ago when Joan
Chen who played Josie wrote a letter to
David Lynch prior to the return when
they started to film it
she wrote it in character as Josie and
she was basically asking him to write
her into the new story it's really a
funny thing the Hollywood Reporter put
it out if I remember correctly and it's
really funny she's talking about being
trapped in the wood and all that kind of
stuff and she mentions that well because
that she is stuck in the wood then maybe
her sister would be in the you know in
the upcoming season and that she could
play her and he or she's referring to
Judy in that same rumor that came from
the revised script in the end though
none of that mattered because they cut
those parts out and in the final script
you know she didn't have as he didn't
mention any sister through the revisions
they also added the bit where Jeffries
was with her in Seattle that wasn't
originally in there so that led to a lot
of theories of Judy being another girl
that had been killed like Laura and
Teresa banks who were also from
Washington State near where all this
stuff kind of happens in other words
Chet Desmond disappeared when he was
going to investigate the death of Teresa
an agent Cooper went missing after
investigating the death of Laura Palmer
so it was a theory that maybe Phillip
Jeffries disappeared when he was
investigating a murdered girl named Judy
so let's look at what mentions there
were of Judy first of all and then we'll
look at what we learned in the return
for as big of a question as who Judy is
has been there
very few mentions of her before these
last couple of episodes when I asked you
guys what you wanted to find out in the
finale last week who was Judi was the
most repeated question by a pretty large
margin and all of that hype came from
just a couple of different little
mentions so in 1987 just before his
disappearance
Phillip Jeffries went to the desk at the
pom deluxe hotel in Buenos Aires and
asked about Miss Judy
the desk clerk gave him a letter that
the young woman had left and this is the
scene that was originally cut from fire
walk with me but we eventually saw it
whenever the missing pieces was released
in the DVD set it's interesting because
the clerk actually refers to her as a
young woman and there's an envelope that
he gives to Jeffries like a physical
thing so that's something to keep in
mind in the main Philip Jeffery scene in
fire walk with me when he comes to the
FBI headquarters in 1989 in Philadelphia
he states to Gordon that he didn't want
to talk about Judy emphasized that she
was positive about this and that he had
found something in Seattle at Judy's
this was the first time we heard the
name Judy and where the whole mystery
began later and fire walk with me a
monkey appears on screen and it's
probably in the black lodge but we can't
really tell for sure because it's just a
close-up but it said Judy's name and
until the return came out that was it
there was no other mentions obviously
this was a fire walk with me
introduction so there was nothing in the
original series and season three evil
coupe found Jeffries at the Dutchman's
which is basically the convenience store
that moves around and asked to know
where Judy was and whether Jefferies and
Judy had wanted something from Cooper
you remember he said you know why don't
you want to talk about Judy who's Judy
and he's kind of insistent about it but
eventually Jeffries gives him some
numbers tells him that he's already met
Judy and then sends him back outside you
know
through the phone line so we don't
really find out much except for the fact
that evil Cooper has an interest in
where Judy is then in the first half of
the season finale in part 17 Gordon Cole
drops the big info bomb where he tells
Albert and Tammy this for 25 years I've
kept something from new Albert before he
disappeared major Briggs shared with me
and Cooper his discovery of an entity an
extreme negative force called in olden
times shall day over time it's become
Judi major Briggs Cooper and I put
together a plan that could lead us to
Judy and then something happened to
major Briggs and something happened to
Cooper Phillip Jeffries who doesn't
really exist anymore at least not in a
normal sense told me a long time ago he
was on to this entity and he disappeared
now the last thing Cooper told me was if
I disappear like the others do
everything you can to find me I'm trying
to kill two birds with one stone and now
this thing of two Cooper's and recently
a paid informant named Raymond row sent
a cryptic message indicating that the
Cooper we met at prison is looking for
coordinates coordinates from a certain
major Briggs so Philip Jeffries was onto
Judy before he disappeared and told
Gordon about it
Judy then was discovered by major Briggs
who collaborated with Gordon Cole and
Cooper on a plan to contain it so what
exactly does this all mean well I think
Cole's description of an entity an
extreme negative force fits pretty well
into a world where we have a white lodge
and a fireman that seems to be in
opposition to someone or some thing it's
not a big stretch then to apply this
idea to what we saw in episode 8 during
the nuclear explosion at the Trinity
test site the experiment where the
mother who spewed forth Bob and the eggs
sure looks a lot like Judy at this point
I mean the firemen jumped into action
right away and created Laura right after
seeing that on his screen the original
name Jail day is a
less clear and that it depends on how
it's spelled most people think it's
Chinese which is a language I don't
speak and that means I'm not really
qualified to say there are plenty
theories out there that have popped up
but I can't validate any of them in the
subtitles it's spelled phonetically I
would guess child a j o w d a why I've
seen two spellings in Chinese which both
could make sense but in completely
different ways J I a o de means screened
so it could be like this is a entity
that's negative and like a scream and
the way that it cuts through things or
whatever ji a o da I means to explain
which this is popular because people are
talking about the idea that David Lynch
doesn't like to explain things because
when you explain something to someone it
kills the mystery it takes away the
chance to enjoy it for what it is once
it's laid bare so that that's a popular
theory that it might be that jail day
but either way we don't really know
these are just things to add into the
conversation but don't don't really say
anything for sure does all this mean the
experiment is actually Judy not a
hundred percent and the reason I say
that is because judy is a negative force
that at least at one time
Philip Jeffries thought was a young
woman in Buenos Aires in that way
nothing that we saw could actually be
Judy but just be under Judy's control
what we know is that Bob came into the
world at that point at the point where
she or it or whatever was vomiting
during the nuclear explosion eggs came
into the world as well and we saw one of
them hatch years later in the desert of
New Mexico we know that a moth frog
creature came out of the egg and crawled
into a sleeping girl's mouth beyond that
we know that the girl happened to be
sleeping because a woodsman came into
her town and repeated a hypno
verse over the radio station she was
listening to also have been seen hanging
out around the convenience store or the
Dutchman's and when evil coupe asked
them to see Phil Jeffries they took him
to him so initially to me it seemed like
the woodsman had a connection to evil
coupe since they always showed up when
he gets shot and we knew that evil coupe
was looking for Judy since he asked
Jeffries about her we also know that he
described what he was looking for as the
symbol that was on the east of space he
shows Daria that symbol looks a lot like
the experiment and we see that same
symbol on Hawkes Matt when Frank asked
hawk about the symbol he says you don't
ever want to know about that and this is
in the context of them talking about
fire symbols black corn and black fire
fire symbols being something like
modern-day electricity that can be good
or bad based on the attention
furthermore the fireman aka the giant
seems to not only be working against
Judy the experiments a mother or the
mother of all evil whatever you want to
call this entity but he also seems to be
working against evil coupes since he's
carrying Bob around with him we know
that he visited Freddy to give him the
green glove and sent him to Twin Peaks
which is how we know that round of
fighting was won we know that he sent
evil coupe there and that's what made
that all possible really simply evil
coupe was looking for the mother of all
evil aka Judy but the firemen intervened
to make sure he ended up finding the
green gloved hero Freddy
instead I mentioned in my finale recap
and reaction video that I believe Sarah
Palmer strange behavior in season 3
short looks a lot like she's been
possessed by Judy and this was brought
to mind in the scene where we see her
smashing the photo after Cooper saves
Laura for being killed and when you pull
back from the characters that we know
from the original season it's kind of
interesting to think about that in
episode 8 we saw the fireman create this
golden orb that was Laura and send it to
Washington in reaction to the idea that
Bob had come for
the mother of all evil so we know Sarah
and we know Laura from the original run
as being mother and daughter that were
all tied up in this story but it's also
the same as looking at them as this
golden orb and possibly the thing that
spewed the Bob orb you see what I'm
saying because of what Gordon told us a
lot of this stuff actually falls into
place and we had the glass box in New
York which is a mystery and there was an
entity that came through there plus in
them in the mob zone we had someone
knocking at the door when NIDA was there
and when the American girl was there so
I don't know if we could say that any of
these things are exactly Judy but
they're probably all under control of
Judy which is the mother of all evil is
kind of the best way to describe it
there's a lot of other little clues and
things and ways that are it's tied
together but we've always looked at Bob
as this embodiment of the evil that men
do or whatever and now we have something
that's actually bigger and probably been
around for a lot longer so it's pretty
interesting
I guess I'll stop it there I want to
hear what you guys had to think I was
doing a breakdown but I got into this
rabbit hole about Judy so I just decided
to make this video first but there's
gonna be more finale stuff coming out
this week also like I said I did launch
my patreon I want to thank everyone
who's come over there already and I want
to ask you guys again to come over as a
incentive I'm super excited about the
final dossier now like I'm once I get
done with all this finale stuff I'm
gonna go back through the secret history
again because now that we know about all
those inconsistencies and how they may
have been from the alternate timeline or
the alternate timeline I can't wait to
see what we find out in the next book so
what I'm going to do is the final
dossier release is the 31st of October
so everyone that signs up for my patreon
and is active on October 31st I'm going
to put all those names in a virtual bag
and I'll pick one name at random and
send that winner a copy of the book
directly through the mail so definitely
check it out make sure you like this
video if you enjoyed
let me know in the comments what else
you want to learn about with these
finale videos we don't have any new
episodes coming and the books not coming
out for a month but I'm still as hyped
as ever about Twin Peaks so people who
are in the patreon will get to vote will
probably I'll probably just have votes
for a couple a month I'll have to do
other shows to keep yous coming in but
I'll do a couple Twin Peaks videos a
month that the patreon will get to
decide on make sure you've subscribed to
my channel if you haven't already turn
on notifications thanks for watching
guys I'll talk to you soon